When you think about Batman, your mind probably
goes to the grim avenger who stalks Gotham
City by night dishing out a darker brand of
justice, and you're not wrong.
That's the image that’s made Batman one
of the most popular superheroes to ever hit
the comics page, and propelled him to success
in TV and movies as well.
Since 1939, though, there have been thousands
of stories about Batman, and sometimes things
get pretty weird.
From bizarre adventures to long-lost relatives,
there are more than a handful of things about
Batman that DC Comics would probably be happy
for readers to forget.
The Dark Knockoff
After his debut in 1938, Superman's sudden
and overwhelming success prompted a massive
crowd of imitators, but Batman was different.
The darker costume, the menacing demeanor,
and even the fact that he didn't have super-powers
helped him to stand out in the crowd, but
"unique" isn't really the right word for him.
Bill Finger and Bob Kane were pretty much
just ripping off the Shadow.
The first Batman story, "The Case of the Chemical
Syndicate," appeared in Detective Comics #27
in 1939.
But three years earlier, the Shadow, a pulp
hero known for his dark costume, and menacing
demeanor, starred in a novel called "Partners
of Peril."
To say that Batman's first adventure "borrowed"
from that story is the understatement of the
century.
It's a beat-for-beat adaptation, right on
down to Batman's early penchant for guns and
his identity being revealed as a millionaire
socialite.
The good news is that within a few months,
Finger and artists like Jerry Robinson and
Sheldon Moldoff had more fully separated the
Caped Crusader from his inspiration.
And hey, at least he's not alone.
Just ask Superman if he knows anything about
Clark "Doc" Savage and the arctic Fortress
of Solitude he had in 1938.
My brother, my Deadman, and me
Way back in 1974’s World's Finest #223,
Bob Haney and Dick Dillin told a story so
weird that even Batman himself referred to
it as "the most stunning, shocking thing that
ever happened in my whole life…which has
not exactly been dull."
In a team-up with Superman and the ghostly
Deadman, Batman followed the trail of a murderer
who killed his victims with gigantic razor-sharp
boomerangs, and discovered that the man he
was hunting was actually the brother he never
knew.
It seems his big bro Thomas Wayne Jr. had
been driven insane by a car accident from
when he was a baby.
He learned how to make boomerangs as part
of his therapy, and was then manipulated into
a very complicated murder spree.
And that's not even the weird part.
That happens at the end of the story, when
Deadman, a ghostly superhero with the ability
to possess the living, just decides to take
over Thomas' body as his new flesh-and-blood
home, without ever telling Batman.
Instead, he just assumes that his "buddy”
Batman would be cool with it, and wanders
off to have his own adventures.
Needless to say, while we would eventually
see more of Thomas Jr., no other creators
ever referenced this particular story again.
Alfred goes bad
Speaking of weird things that have happened
to the Batman family, Alfred's brief tenure
as a telekinetic crime boss who looked like
a humanoid golf ball is also something that
we don't really talk about anymore.
In 1964, Jack Schiff and Sheldon Moldoff seemingly
killed off Batman's butler Alfred, having
him sacrifice his life to save the Dynamic
Duo.
Six months later, though, Batman faced a new
foe: The Outsider.
For almost two years, the Outsider challenged
Batman and Robin, acting as a mastermind who
manipulated other villains.
And when they finally confronted him, he was
revealed to be Alfred.
It turned out their faithful butler had been
resurrected by a scientist whose "regeneration
machine" turned him into a mutant who hated
his former employers.
Fortunately, the process turned out to be
extremely easy to reverse, and before long,
he was back to dusting the Batcave.
And believe it or not, this one actually did
get referenced again later on.
Nocturna’s custody battle
If you’re a casual Batman fan, you might
think that he only did weird stuff back in
the long-ago days of the Silver Age.
Once the ‘80s rolled around with Dark Knight
Returns and Death in the Family, things got
dark and serious, right?
Sure, as long as “dark and serious” includes
a vampire taking Batman to court to get custody
of Robin.
It happened in 1983 with Natalia Knight, who
was about as close as you could get to a vampire
without actually having someone get bitten
on the neck.
While working as an astronomer, she was zapped
by a weird ray that drained her skin of pigmentation
and left her super-sensitive to light, so
naturally, she decided to become a supervillain
named Nocturna.
Like you do.
She also fell into a love quadrangle with
Vicki Vale and Alfred's daughter, Julia, who
were all vying for Bruce Wayne's affections.
The thing is, rather than long walks on the
beach, Nocturna's strategy involved waiting
for Bruce to adopt a new ward, Jason Todd,
and then adopting him first so that Bruce
would have to marry her if he really wanted
to be a Bat-dad.
The weirdest part?
It almost worked.
Jason actually said in court that he'd prefer
to be adopted by Natalia, only to reveal later
that it had all been part of an ill-fated
attempt at going undercover.
Eventually, Nocturna was seemingly killed
in a hot air balloon crash, no, really, and
that was the end of the world's most complicated
marriage proposal.
Electric Death
When you think about Batman's greatest enemies,
the names that usually come to mind are the
big ones.
The Joker.
Ra's al-Ghul.
You can even make a pretty decent argument
for the Riddler, if you really put your mind
to it.
But if you're going by who actually had the
most success at the goal of actually killing
Batman, then the Dark Knight's greatest foe
is actually a guy named Lester Buchinsky:
the Electrocutioner!
Yeah, it’s hard to believe, especially since
he technically killed Batman by accident.
The Electrocutioner was another vigilante
who figured that if you couldn't bring the
criminals to the electric chair, you might
as well bring the electric chair to them.
In a 1992 story from Detective Comics, he
and Batman were on the trail of the same criminal.
When the Electrocutioner zapped him with a
shock big enough to stop his heart, Batman
was technically dead for a good minute and
a half.
The only reason that he didn't stay that way
was that Robin was there, and had the good
sense to wear an insulated costume.
While the Electrocutioner originally just
shrugged off literally killing the Batman,
Robin eventually beat enough sense into him
that he agreed to use his electric gloves
as a defibrillator to shock Batman back to
life.
And then they both presumably agreed to never
again speak of the time Batman almost died
in a sewer at the hands of a D-List schlub
that had to be beaten into compliance by a
spiky haired teenager with a stick.
The Dark Knockoff Returns
With Batman’s popularity, it's no surprise
that Gotham City would become a pretty important
place in the DC Universe.
The last 75 years have seen a history develop
for the Dark Knight's hometown that's also
seen it serve as the home of other superheroes
from throughout the timeline of the DC Universe.
The Golden Age Green Lantern, a violent vigilante
called the Reaper who was around in the years
before Bruce Wayne's parents were killed,
and even cowboy antihero Jonah Hex, who was
hanging around there back in the 1800s, and
also in the future.
It’s complicated.
Of course, it's one thing if Batman's not
the first superhero to make his home in Gotham
City.
But if he's not actually the first Gotham
superhero to dress up as a bat, well…that's
a little weird.
In 1998, an unexpected tale in the pages of
Chase, a short-lived but underrated comic
series, revealed that Cameron Chase's distrust
of masked avengers came from the fact that
her father was one: the Acro-Bat, who fought
crime in the ‘70s alongside an obscure and
hilariously named team called the Justice
Experience.
Unsurprisingly, his story doesn't end well,
but once you know he was out there, it's hard
to not think that Bruce Wayne was biting his
style.
The Corpse that Wouldn’t Die!
The Electrocutioner wasn't the only one to
score a (technical) kill on Batman.
In The Brave and the Bold #115, however, the
culprit was even less impressive: a booby-trapped
rain-spout rigged up by a couple of completely
average criminals.
The shock did him in, but thanks to Batman's
"iron constitution" keeping his heart beating,
he's only mostly dead.
Fortunately, the Atom gets the bright idea
to solve the Batman's "final" case by shrinking
down and hopping around on his brain in hopes
that this will stimulate his crime-fighting
instincts and allow him to mindlessly do things
like punch out crooks and rescue a kidnapped
girl.
And it actually works.
It turns out that having a little tiny man
hop on your brain is enough stimulus to basically
jumpstart everything and get you back in good
working order.
It might not be that great for the legend
of the Batman to have him die at random by
jumping at the wrong window, but that's balanced
out by the fact that death itself cannot stop
him from getting up off a slab in the morgue
and busting criminals' jaws all over Gotham
City.